Grant's girlfriend Gloria is super proud of Grant for all of his glasses viper
success. But she actually has a very successful as well. She's a wildlife
conservation specialist. In fact, she just got some really exciting news. She's
about to go to China for a couple of months to work at a giant panda sanctuary,
a nature preserve that protects pandas to help their population rebuild. Gloria
needs to learn all about how pandas became an endangered species, and how
effective different conservation efforts have been, so that she can be as
helpful as possible during her time in China. Now, the preserve she's going to
has actually made a ton of progress in helping its panda population grow.
Here's a graph showing how the number of pandas in the sanctuary has changed
form year to year. The horizontal axis here shows the number of years that have
passed since the opening of the sanctuary, and the vertical axis shows the
number of pandas living there. How many pandas did the sanctuary start out
with? In other words, how many did they have after 0 years? How many did they
have after 10 years? How about have 22 years? And lastly, what about after 30
years? That's this last data point which represents now.